[Applause]
the Iraqi forces have been here before
they know is cybers linger behind when
the street battles appear over purely to
impede their progress to kill and to
maim so they go careful
[Applause]
after hours of standoff the bulldozer
clears the way so the military convoy in
advance but while we're filming an is
flag in the center this happens huge
bomb huge dramatist
gone off very very close to the truth we
know that there is an is thrown above
it's a suicide car bomb probably hidden
in the garage whilst its driver waited
for the soldiers and police to close in
the Iraqi forces hit back and hard
they're still trying to locate the
snipers but then a second car bomb is
spotted driving towards us
second they within about half an hour
and there's two is true where everyone
is an hour back in their push by now
their intelligence says a third car bomb
is on its way to the Troops
we're sheltering with some of them
there's a lot of nervous tension they
know it's coming they just don't know
when
then with gunfire sounding all around
them families began to emerge those who
could barely walk were helped by younger
relatives others were lifted out of the
firing line by the waiting Iraqi forces
many of them were in a state of distress
[Music]
some seemed unable to grasp they'd
actually made it out alive
many of these civilians have spoken of
being intimidated and to stay with is
who then use them as human shields to
ward off attacks by the us-led coalition
this is urban warfare at its most
difficult
ten hours after they set out and even
using smoke screens the troops were
still being tested by snipers targeting
their every move
[Applause]
airstrikes were called for without these
the Iraqi forces know the situation
would be a lot more difficult the Iraqi
forces do have the upper hand but this
is going to be a very painful victory
Alex Crawford sky news in West Mosul